you told me the story of the war when  the ground shook in the sky burn  of the ones that survived  who will woke to a different world where  the powerful prey of me  but that's not the way it has to be when  I found you  you're very human brain was miraculously  it's the loneliest feeling not to know  who you are in time you'll remember  [Music]  the leaders knew again it's a harsh  world down here do that'll be willing to  do what it takes I'll eat that run  [Music]  Mika's she's the last of a kind  she contains technology that have been  lost for 300 years  let me show you something  [Music]  this body I feel a connection to it I  can't explain you know more about me  than you're saying  Leda some things have better left  forgotten and I'll find out for myself  she's threatening the natural water  thing I need you to destroy her  Leda they will come for you I'll have to  face them head-on  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I'm with her  you